i want to talk about something really
crazy check this out
so everybody knows there's a gas
shortage it's it's all over the news
as much as the new york times and some
other outlets might want to lie about it
but one when we're look when i'm looking
up stories trying to get more details on
this
something really interesting happens
when you google search gas shortage
what's the date you find on some of
these stories 1970.
no no yeah for sure 1979 jimmy carter of
course of course people are
you know was it biden jr compared uh
biden to carter and it's like
what do you tweets like i guess i guess
my my tweet on this is aging like fine
wine no no no
no the the the hack happened on friday
what was what was friday was that the
seventh that was the seventh yep the
seventh
so you but you google google search gas
shortage you'll find stories going back
to
april 27th april 29th whoa whoa whoa
how was there a news cycle about gas
shortages
before the hack even happened and it's
one thing if it was like a few months
before they were like economists predict
no it's like a few days
before this happened we were getting
these predictions checked out cnn
business coming this summer
gas stations running out of gas check
this out abc news
lack of truck drivers could lead to fuel
shortage this summer
and we've got this on fox business truck
driver i'm sorry yes it's from may 3rd
may 3rd
truck driver shortage could fuel spike
in gas prices
this to me is just very very interesting
timing
yeah does any one of those articles talk
about why there's a shortage in
truck drivers uh i mean we produce more
oil and gas than ever before
in the year 2019 and 2020 we never seem
to have a
shortage of truck drivers here's what
abc news says where do they go
as millions of americans return to
driving and planning summer road
trips experts are warning that some gas
stations could face fuel shortages quote
we are not looking at a shortage of
gasoline jeanette mcgee
a aaa spokesperson said in an interview
with abc news in fact we have ample
supply in the us
to get to the summer and the rest of the
year what the concern is right now is a
shortage of fuel truck drivers first
reported by cnn
the national truck i'm sorry the
national tank truck carriers
the industry's trade groups that between
20 percent and 25 of tank trucks in the
fleet
are parked last year during the pandemic
many of the drivers retired
or they went to different industries and
that created a shortage
truck drivers also need special training
to haul oil
and some driving schools have closed
amid the pandemic exacerbating the
problem
some areas have begun to see the effects
of the driver shortage particularly las
vegas
and northwest arkansas mcgee said
vacation hot spots near beaches or in
the mountains in particular
could feel the biggest effects someone
super chatted us this they said there's
a trucker shortage and it's going gonna
it could result in supply shortages you
go to walmart oh already what was it you
were saying you couldn't find bacon
yeah we were looking for bacon actually
at costco the other day you couldn't
find baby find it anywhere the four pack
of bacon that's like the most
inexpensive bacon in the world yeah
can't find a baby yeah so
i just find it absolutely fascinating
that we have these news stories
talking about this trucker shortage a
week ago the cyber attack happens
perhaps coincidence
but the the new emergency regulations
allow truck drivers to drive more than
their allotted hours
when did that regulation get put into
effect after the cyber attack wow
isn't it just um i'm not asserting
anything other than oh i will what a
very interesting coincidence yeah we
have to
just i'll just lay it out thank you tim
a week before the cyber attack
there aren't enough truck drivers warns
cnn abc
and fox this could result in rising gas
prices
and it could result in gasoline
shortages so how do you
compensate how would how would a normal
person compensate for a lack of drivers
well outside of any cyber attack you'd
say can we can we increase the amount of
hours
the oil haulers are allowed to drive
well there's a federal
federal regulation barring that well i
guess coincidentally
a national emergency or a regional
emergency 17 states in dc
and now the drivers are allowed to drive
over there over there a lot of times
you could eliminate that problem
altogether
if you just build pipelines i know isn't
it great right it's greener
it's cheaper it's safer it's it's yeah
let me ask you um
a lot of people proponents of the
keystone pipeline said that there's
actually more leaks
i think ian brought up you looked up
there were like 26 leaks from keystone
or something yeah but are there you know
i guess
per gallon are there more leaks from
freight and and train oh absolutely and
it's well documented
that pipelines are by far safer cleaner
greener um and what i care most about
the more cost efficient for the american
consumer
undisputed and and and proof of the
matter is
um the amount of pipeline we have i mean
we have
we have enough pipelines to go to the
moon and back 10 times in america
right we have we have almost 3 million
miles worth of pipeline crossing this
country
this place we're in probably has
multiple gas pipelines all throughout
the walls and people like i'm afraid of
pipelines
well you can't be that afraid because
you do go to your home
right so our pipeline capacity in
america is absurd
um but it is vulnerable clearly the
cyber attacks so
keystone was going to be bringing in
from like the tar sands areas alberta
canada
yeah the only reason why the president
got involved in keystone is because it
crossed an international border
right and now they're trying to use that
as a premise to shut down other
pipelines but he is not a czar nor
neither president nor trump nor nor
biden could go into
a state and say i want to shut down this
pipeline within the state of minnesota
that's not your prerogative he's going
to try to make it his prerogative and
this is where thank god we have the 10th
amendment and hopefully a court system
that upholds it and says but yeah i
don't know either
isn't uh i think canada is suing now
over this yeah as they should because
canada
followed all of the rules to get this
pipeline approved
i don't know what the statute of
limitation is for a presidential
executive order
they went through all the necessary
paperwork starting years ago starting in
the obama administration
obama never rejected it he just kept it
on the balance in forever forever
forever
and then finally trump became president
well they were hoping hillary would be
the one to have to give the big no
she didn't win trump won okay boom let's
get the pipeline started is it
so we had uh we had max kaiser and
stacey herbert on the show last night
and they were talking about
you know the us dollars the reserve
currency so we got to send it out
otherwise it's not the reserve currency
so they print this money they give it to
these foreign countries
to maintain the status as the reserve
currency i guess because the u.s doesn't
make a whole lot and we're being given
all the stuff because we print money
but i wonder if you know and you're the
energy guys so correct me if this is not
true or will not correct me but i'll
assert i'll ask the question is the
reason why the
the democratic establishment or the
political establishment establishment
general doesn't want to produce fossil
fuels here
is because they want to use the us
reserve currency to have other countries
do it
and maintain you know our status abroad
um
i would say that they don't want to
produce fossil fuels because it's one of
the biggest if not the biggest industry
that is not controlled by the state
and i think at this point the modern
democrat party is a statist
party and the fossil fuel and it's kind
of what obama did with
with health care right he wanted to
centralize health care under the purview
of the federal government
because that's just what big statists
think
um venezuela has national energy most of
the european countries have national
energy
exactly and i think they hate this
industry in particular
climate change and all that stuff is
just a very good vehicle
to accomplish what they want and what
they want is a state
run they look at they want to
nationalize the election system
you're right right they like
nationalizing and centralizing
everything industry whatever we we had
this uh this phd pathologist guy on the
show um
and he was talking about like insect
species collapse
and you know the ramifications of human
population it's expansive there's
ocean acidification and i think that
crisis is absolutely exploited i know a
lot of conservatives don't agree they
think it's a lot of you know propaganda
i think it's i think it's a crisis and i
think it's exploited to the most absurd
degree notably
when we're talking about the border
crisis what was it kamala harris was
like
the crisis is caused by climate change
and it was funny because conservatives
but predicted they're like camilarius is
going to go up on the podium and say
climate change caused the crisis
and she did it and it's just absolutely
absurd but they i i believe they
absolutely this is their go-to
to seize power i'd be willing to bet has
more to do with
consolidating power within the state
like you mentioned it's just it's it's
not a
federal controlled industry or whatever
and they want that power and climate
change
is a wonderful villain because it is
faceless it is nameless and
it and you are powerless against it so
for example you take someone like gavin
russon
who talks about the fires in california
are caused
by climate change which is crazy because
southern oregon doesn't have that level
of fires western nevada doesn't have
that level of fires
southeast idaho doesn't have southwest
idaho doesn't have that level
why is just california climate change
well now i am
i am absolved of forest management i am
absolved of running the state
because it's climate change remember
remember when they uh criticized trump
trump tweeted out you know they've it's
poor poor forest management they're like
oh geez trump's so dumb
and there's actually an article from
like a year before it was like
california's not managing their forests
properly it's going to result in fires
not only that but i think one of the
wildfires was caused by electrical
companies
not shutting off the the grid pg e yeah
yeah so it like
sparked and like ignited things and
they're like well clearly that was
because of
you know the co2 levels but i'll tell
you this look
i think you know i talk to some very
smart people and they say there's
concerns about
what happens we have too many people
it's not it's you know a lot of people
think overpopulation is like we're all
standing shoulder to shoulder no it's
just
a lot of waste is produced and it can
upset the upset the delicate balance of
an ecosystem
unfortunately for the people who are
environmentalists and really advocating
for this stuff i got to say
you have lost the trust of so many
people when barack obama buys beachfront
property
when when these wealthy investors go and
buy uh
miami beach property while complaining
that miami is sinking yeah so i'm sorry
dude it's really hard to generate trust
and if you if you're somebody who wants
you know republican
these democrats are like republicans
gotta get on board and fight climate
change well you gotta start with
you know your your thought leaders not
flying in private jets
not owning massive 50 bedroom homes and
not
buying this beachfront property i saw
this video it was actually
really compelling not in the way i think
a lot of conservatives
expected it to be for me there's a guy
he's a financial guy and he says
the one thing that he believes disproves
climate change is that
in miami beach they're still selling
these multi-million dollar expensive
properties
and these very wealthy individuals who
are supposed to be in the know are
buying them
on 30-year mortgages and he says how is
it when they receive like a prospectus
or like an investment packet
it doesn't say warning in in 10 years
this will be underwater and worth
zero how is that well when i saw that
what it said to me was
these people either don't believe their
own their own pitches
or they're absolutely just willing to
exploit people by buying property they
know it's going to be bunk and then
selling it later
or just going like extracting as much as
they can from the system
as they ride it all the way to the
gutter well i mean this administration
is is making a huge push that
all industry all business has to have a
climate
component and and the products you
create whatever you manufacture
the the the effect on the climate has to
be built into price
real estate seems to be exempt from that
so you're absolutely right like if
you're bank of america and you're like
we can't finance this because it's bad
for climate change
well you gave a 30-year mortgage on a
house in an area that's going to be
underwater and 15.
is that a good investment of your money
so you're you're right like i'm i'm not
saying that
this should happen but i'm saying it's
funny that the banks are not pricing
real estate
into this industry i got a solution
what's the regulatory body that deals
with the
would that be the sec or the ft it would
be the ftc would it with uh
it wouldn't be the sec dealing with like
um when a bank gives out a bunk
loan isn't that fdic fdic i think
that's insurance okay how about this
here's here's what i got to say
i'll be sec banking security securities
in exchange that's a security imagine
um maybe a little bit of both of ftc uh
how about this
conservatives and democrats can come
together okay not the ultra-rich
property owners just the regular
working-class people disagree
and here's one issue they can come
together on
these banks that are giving out loans on
these properties in miami beach
on 30-year mortgages or even 15-year
mortgages
how about we send the feds after them
for fraud
and i think the democrats who think
climate change is a serious problem
we've got 12 years left
would agree and i think the
conservatives who see these people as
exploiting the
the crisis in order to make for personal
gain hey why not
if these people want to come out and say
you know oh there's a big crisis
but then they're selling these expensive
properties and giving out these loans
send the feds they'll give them a
million-dollar loan
they're like you know what if it goes
underwater in 15 years my dollar is
going to be worth a hundred million
dollars anyway
because of inflation so i'll just pay
off that loan not even
risk loss i'd be willing to but the
banks are like look in the event that
it's underwater in 15 years we just get
the taxpayer to bail it out you're fine
yeah it'll be it'll be a crisis fema
will come in they'll start building
uh these emergency sea walls for you you
don't got to worry about a thing and it
won't come out of your pocket
the government will keep printing money
for you and the banks it's the poor
people who got to work extra hard to get
that emergency
you know the emergency uh circumstance
solved yeah
there's just there's there's not
physical evidence of
climate change and now someone is
listening to this right now and their
head is about to explode media matters
just clipped that and they're like
exactly but but i mean they'll they'll
show you the california wildfires
they'll talk about
and we hear this phrase all the time
especially from this administration the
severity and the intensity and the
frequency of storms
if you look at 30-year of tornadoes of
hurricanes
there is no more severity intensity or
frequency of storms
the data is is fairly flat there are bad
years absolutely there are some really
bad years
there are some empty years but but over
30 40 50 years the data is
is pretty evident and for me the biggest
evidence that that this climate change
thing is used
i'm not saying climate change doesn't
exist i'm saying the way it is it is
used by the left for political purposes
for me the biggest evidence is that the
same bodies that have been talking about
climate change
for most of my life now i was a
sophomore in high school the first time
i heard about global warming
and and united nations environmental
program unip
you can still see the article online
they talk about uh
we have 10 years left to fix this 1989
shows you my age by the year 2000
the maldives were going to be underwater
they said a half of bangladesh was going
to be underwater
they talked about huge catastrophe not
only did it not come true
but those agencies have never said why
their data was so wrong what formulation
did they use what what algorithms
what calculation and modeling did they
use and how did they fix it
i've never been able to see their fixed
show your work when
they don't when i was in grade school
they had us go over uh a prediction for
peak oil consumption
yeah jimmy carter said it was by the
year 2076 when he was running for
re-election i
i don't remember exactly but i think it
was like 2010 it was like the bell curve
was crap like the curve was crashing and
it was like there's no oil left and
that's when we're screwed
i grew up thinking oil and gas were
finite commodities that would be
exhausted i'm at the point now that i
think they're
not infinite but they're clearly
replenishing because we find more oil
and gas every time we turn around
it's ridiculous i think there's probably
a lot yes but i also think that
um we've been able to synthesize it and
so
this idea that we have to dramatically
transform the whole planet
because of uh you know because of the
fear of like piqua or whatever
we could synthesize it and maintain our
current infrastructure may just be
different
i i have no problem with going green as
a concept i i i have nothing against
solar and wind
one of the things i try to do is say we
have to see the costs and not just the
physical dollar costs
but but the costs to human flourishing
if we do this because there is going to
be a lot of suffering
you mentioned right now when when greta
said i'm talking right now no more oil
and gas
well there's a lot of people right now
who are experiencing it millions would
die
literally overnight no no i mean
literally
the people who require insulin it's got
to be refrigerated
you shut what do these people think the
power plants run on
you know farts smug sense of self
satisfaction of these
oh we'll build solar plants at night how
do you you have no batteries
i love the idea of new technology i
don't like the idea of holding back
development
for the sake of existing you know i
don't like the argument of like oh no we
gotta protect jobs
we do i think we should have new
technology nuclear fusion whatever
but this idea that you can come out
right now and just shut it down oh okay
well people will starve to death
people will freeze to death diabetics
will all die because they don't have
refrigerator won't be able to
refrigerate their insulin we've never
advanced as a society
by banning something that is currently
in use we offer better alternatives and
the marketplace and a free people
adopt them freely we have never said
that this is the way to go and therefore
this is now illegal
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you